whose bull-riding for that's a tough
question I know for me it was a metaphor
for life
I'm Gary Leffew I have a traveling bull
riding school where we go all over the
country all over the world with it I was
never good at anything first time I did
it but I was willing to if I loved doing
it I would willing to persevere and take
gas chickens the embarrassments whatever
it took to get to that end result which
was to get good at it to get excellent
at it
we're in Pennsylvania right out of
Harrisburg Pennsylvania and we're doing
a school for these Yankees up here
they'd like to ride bulls and there's
quite a few of them
I've talked 13 worlds champion so maybe
my 14th to come out of this area Gary's
been instructing bull riding for over 40
years it takes somebody special to be
able to teach in a way that a broad
spectrum of students is going to be able
to grasp mister Leffew has got it down
to a science
welcome to the school we've had some
good ones up here as far as bull riding
teaching going I go by the theory if you
want to be the best find the best in
copy so literally what I did was take
the most productive bull riders in
history and study all the video of them
and slow it down break it down find out
what they were doing different than
other guys Justin McBride and some of
these guys that I think Justin went 6
million by the time he was 29 here's a
guy that just does it perfect you know
so we watch video of him and you see
that back in come up there and then I
started to put drills to it because I
used to wrestle and then wrestling every
move had drills and you did those drills
over and over and over and over again
roll here pump over in the pocket do it
there you go to the point where you move
everything over to the left side of your
brain
you know before you get on a bowl the
really good writers I work on clearing
their head
so the less you think about the better
off you are once you climb down on the
bull your rosin in your rope you're
putting your hand in the rope you're
getting the bull adjusted to where he's
standing good you get your wrap once the
gate opens as you look over not your
head you look at the bull he's moving
then you're finding your Center balance
well many times when when things don't
go so good out there and you get and you
get thrown you're trying to hit the
ground and roll and get the hell out of
there or crawl whatever it takes to get
away from that pool and that's what the
bullfighters are there for their job is
to get in there and distract that bull
sometimes they can't not there he's got
his mind on you you know so sometimes
you get smoked you get run over bull
riding is definitely an individual sport
but it can't happen without a group of
people you're going to have your Rider
the rope puller possibly a spotter if
it's a little acting up you're always
going to have a flank man a gate man and
a latch man
the exciting and cool thing about
putting on these schools is you never
quite are sure what kind of student
you're going to see show up last year we
had a guy that was riding already at the
top level on TV just coming for a
tune-up - we definitely have people that
are using the school is like their
version of a skydiving weekend and it's
on their bucket list it happened I was
four years old I walked into the TV room
and my older sister was watching the PBR
on TV and I looked up seeing these cool
Cowboys just riding bulls and right then
in there I knew that's what I wanted to
do and I did whatever I could to make it
happen
I want to be a world champion bull rider
in the PBR that's my goal if I die my
kids are gonna be so mad at me I mean
it's a real thought that runs through
your head you can't have fear or it
can't be anywhere present in in the
arena with you it can't be in your
subconscious because that fear is going
to come and it's going to buck you off
and take you down to the ground it helps
you in every other aspect of your life
because you can't fear anything if you
want to succeed
I think the danger of the sport is what
makes it appealing to me because the
battlin and rodeo is not with animals
with the weakness in yourself you get
off and there's an adrenaline rush there
there's Bobby endorphins running three
that just you just so excited from the
experience that you want to do it again
lot of guys can come to find something
about themselves I get all kinds of
stories like that guys that left will
run and become multimillionaires in
business the attitude and the philosophy
they learned about riding a bull carries
over business as well because what is
tougher to look at everyday than an 1800
pound matter sale bull